If you want to see pretty much 100% proof
that Sister Irene from The Nun is related
to Lorraine Warren from the Conjuring,
then stick around to the end of this video.
[intro]
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
If you haven’t already seen the initial
episode, 34 Things You Missed in The Nun -- you’ll
want to watch that before watching this video.
I mean, I guess there’s no reason you have
to watch them in order -- but the reason I
say that is I don’t want a million people
to comment on this video telling me the things
that I missed that I already covered in the
other video.
One of the first shots we see in the Abbey
is a cross with an infinity symbol in the
middle.
Later on, we see imagery of the snakes, the
symbol of Valak, forming the same symbol as
well.
This may or may not be related to something
known as the Leviathan cross, which looks
like this and is sometimes used as a Satanic
symbol.
During the opening scene, when the Nuns are
attacked by Valak, Sister Jessica mentions
an important detail that plays into the twist
ending.
“Take it!
This evil needs a vessel to escape!”
That’s the reason that Sister Victoria sacrifices
herself, and the reason that Valak is able
to escape the abbey at the end, using Frenchie
as a vessel.
You gotta feel bad for Frenchie.
He’s just minding his own business, finds
a body, probably gets demonetized for it,
then LITERALLY gets demonetized, aka possessed
by a demon… alright clearly this pun isn’t
going anywhere, so I’m gonna move on to
the next Thing You Missed.
So in the other video I pointed out a few
of the hidden Valak messages at the beginning
of the film, and now I’ve found a couple
more.
In the classroom where we first meet Sister
Irene, there are some letters on the wall.
The shape of the chairs right here creates
the V, then if you go up from there you’ll
find the A-L-A-K.
Valak.
Valak is also written wayyy in the background
on the board.
Now that The Nun is out on Blu-Ray I have
the power to pause and take a closer look
at all the words written in Father Burke’s
crossword puzzle.
Here are the ones I found to be significant.
Annointer -- that’s someone who applies
ritualistic oil during a religious ceremony.
In The Nun…
I mean it’s not oil, but Sister Irene is
protected by the blood of the holy grail being
smeared on her forehead, so I feel like there’s
something there.
Aimless -- that’s a word you could use to
describe Frenchie at the beginning of the
story.
"What is it?"
"Mr Devoe?"
"Hi..."
And novice -- this one describes Sister Irene
because she’s young and hasn’t taken her
vows.
Sister Irene helps him fill in the next word,
“deliveries”, and if you think about it,
this may be more than just an instance of
her holy crossword solving skills, but also
a psychic vision, because they end up going
to the deliveries room at the Abbey.
“The icehouse.
It’s where I leave my deliveries.”
Father Burke and Sister Irene are asked to
stay overnight to talk to the other Nuns in
the morning.
During the night, the father is lured out
into the cemetery by the form of a young boy
he performed an exorcism on years before named
Daniel.
If you pause right on the moment the father
shines his flashlight on Daniel, you’ll
notice his eyes are glowing white, similar
to how sister Irene looks later on when she’s
having a vision.
The father ends up being buried alive by Valak,
but thanks to Sister Irene’s abilities as
a medium, she’s able to rescue him, and
they find these books in the coffin.
Two of the books have snake eyes on them,
which is notable because Valak is sometimes
referred to as the marquis of snakes.
"Valak.
The defiler.
The profane.
The marquis of snakes."
...and you’ll later see plenty of snake
imagery when Father Burke sits down to study
the books.
Wait, hold on… roll back on that for a sec.
I think we can use that clip in our next chillhop
video.
I can just imagine the title: “Lo-Fi Chillhop
for Studying / Chilling / Performing an Exorcism.”
I’ve talked previously about how Valak is
a character in the real-world book The Lesser
Key of Solomon, but in that book he looks
more like this, and not really like a Nun.
The books do have some shadowy images of a
more traditional looking demons so I wonder
if those pictures represent the true form
of Valak.
Or maybe Valak is just a big Brendon Urie
fan, I don’t know.
The other document that the father studies
is the map of the abbey, which is labeled
“Castelui Sarpe”, Romanian for “Castle
Snake”.
The map also reveals the locations where Valak
stalks the halls at night, like this tunnel,
where Sister Irene is later attacked.
“Oh God.”
Where does all this wind come from anyway?
Does Valak just have the ability to create
wind?
I mean we see the same thing in The Conjuring
2, but it makes more sense cause there is
a storm outside.
Anyway, when Sister Irene finds Sister Oana’s
body in the chapel, you can see that her hands
have been impaled, painting the grim picture
that she’s been crucified.
During Valak’s attack on the abbey, Father
Burke is investigating off on his own, and
I noticed what I think is a mistake.
It looks like they tried to steal a shot from
another scene or something.
The Father is supposed to be by himself at
this point in the movie… but who’s this?
Also during the attack while Sister Irene
is praying with the other Nuns, there is a
quick cutaway shot to this statue, and the
baby has wings, making it look a lot more
like Valak’s appearance in the Lesser Key
of Solomon.
After the incident is over, the wings are
no longer visible.
Shortly after that we get one more look at
Father Burke’s crossword puzzle.
There are a couple pairs of opposites: execute
& create, obvious references to Christ, and
dawn & dusk, possibly related to the fact
that the nuns take a vow of silence from dusk
until dawn.
He’s also penned in the word reflective.
You may remember that when Frenchy goes to
the pub in town, they mention that they cover
all the mirrors after a death so that the
ghost won’t see it’s reflection.
Sister Irene’s first encounter with Valak
is through a mirror in the chapel.
The last word I noticed on the crossword puzzle
is “Wan”.
The film that started it all, The Conjuring,
and it’s sequel, The Conjuring 2 are directed
by James Wan.
Alright… this last one is maybe the biggest
Thing You Missed I’ve ever done.
If I gave out a golden magnifying glass to
the best Thing You Missed, it would go to
this Thing You Missed.
There’s been a theory floating around about
the possible relation between Sister Irene
from The Nun and Lorraine Warren from The
Conjuring.
Both are mediums, and both have intense visions
of past, present and future.
Both have visions and some kind of tie to
Valak.
It seems reasonable to suggest that this is
a trait that can run in the family, due to
the fact that Lorraine’s daughter Judy also
has visions of the Nun.
The Vatican tells Father Burke to take Sister
Irene with him on his journey, because she
supposedly knows the area.
However, upon meeting her, he finds she does
not know the area, but Father Burke claims
the church must have a reason for selecting
her.
"Every decision the Vatican makes is with
purpose.
I'm sure they had their reasons for selecting you."
Finally there’s the fact that the real life
actresses that play Sister Irene and Lorraine
Warren are sisters in real life.
Some have speculated that they’re sisters
in the movie, some say they are the same person
and Sister Irene changes her name later in
life, while some think their similarities
are just coincidence.
However, in The Nun, I think Sister Irene’s
passport would prove otherwise.
Irene Palmer was born on March 2nd 1930 about
three years after Lorraine's date of birth.
Lorraine Warren’s maiden name is Moran,
so that might throw out the theory that they’re
sisters, however, Irene’s place of birth
is listed as Bridgeport, Connecticut -- which
happens to be exactly where Lorraine Warren
was born.
There may be further connections in the deleted
scenes of The Nun, so make sure you subscribe
to CZsWorld to stay up to date on all the
Things You Missed, ring the deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming, we both survive.